DECORUM AND A CIVIL DISCOURSE.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW IS DAN BONGINO,
FORMER SECRET SERVICE AGENT AND
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK, SPYGATE.
ALSO JOINING ME AS ROCHELLE
RITCHIE, FORMER PRESS
SECRETARY FOR THE HOUSE
DEMOCRATS.
WHAT WILL THE DEMOCRATIC
RESPONSE BE IF SOMETHING
HORRIFIC HAPPENS, FOR BOTH
CONGRESSWOMEN AND SENATORS WHO
ARE EITHER TACITLY ENCOURAGING
OR ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING WITH
THEIR WORDS?
>> YOU MENTIONED THAT SOMEONE
MIGHT BE KILLED, AND SOMEONE
ALREADY HAS BEEN KILLED AS A
RESULT OF WHAT'S COMING FROM THE
RIGHT, WITCHES HAD THEIR HAIR.
THEIR HYPOCRISY WE ARE SEEING
COMING FROM REPUBLICANS IS
KILLING OBJECTIVE THINKING.
THE INABILITY OF THE G.O.P. TO
THINK OBJECTIVELY AND TO HOLD
THEMSELVES TO THE SAME ACCORD AS
THEY HAVE HELD EVERYONE ELSE IS
LITERALLY LIKE A PLAGUE THAT IS
SPREADING THROUGHOUT OUR
POLITICS.
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORB
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORN
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORI
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORG
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORO
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORN
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORT
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORE
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORD
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORO
PEOPLE WERE BEGGING ON THE DOORS
OF THE SUPREME COURT AIMLESSLY,
AND IF WE THINK THOSE PEOPLE ARE
A MOB -- >> Laura: IS THAT --
IS THAT WHAT YOU ACTUALLY
CONSIDER TO BE CIVIL PROTEST, OR
WHAT WE SAW WITH ANTIFA IN
PORTLAND?
PREVENTING A CAR OR HARASSING AN
ELDERLY AMERICAN?
>> I DON'T CLAIM ANTIFA, AND
LIKE I JUST SAID A COUPLE
SECONDS AGO I THOUGHT BANGING ON
THE SUPREME COURT DOORS
AIMLESSLY WAS A LITTLE
RIDICULOUS.
CONGRESSMAN CLEAVER WAS ACTUALLY
SPAT ON DURING THE TEA PARTY
MOVEMENT FROM PEOPLE WHO ARE
ANGRY ABOUT OBAMACARE.
SO THAT -- >> Laura: WHO WAS
ENCOURAGING THAT?
NO ONE WAS ENCOURAGING THAT.
NO REPUBLICANS THAT GET IN THEIR
FACES, GO HARASS THEM AT A
RESTAURANT.
DAN BONGINO, LET'S GET YOU IN ON
THIS.
GO AHEAD.
>> I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT WHAT
RICHELLE JUST DID IS REALLY
GROSS AND I WANT TO CALL HER OUT
FOR THAT IMMEDIATELY.
WHAT HAPPENS -- I DIDN'T
INTERRUPT YOU, I'D APPRECIATE IT
IF YOU LET ME SPEAK.
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO BE CIVIL.
>> NOW WE ARE.
>> WHAT YOU DID WAS GROTESQUE,
WHAT YOU DID WAS QUITE GROSS.
DONALD TRUMP AND CONSERVATIVES
TO HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE DERANGED MURDERING
MANIAC WHO RUNS A WOMAN OVER IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
THAT IS GROSS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DENOUNCED OUT
IMMEDIATELY AND YOU ARE BRINGING
IT UP IN THE CONTRACT -- >>
THERE IS GOOD AND BAD ON BOTH
SIDES.
>> JUST TAKE OVER THE DEBATE.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> I'M ALLOWED TO SPEAK NOW.
>> LET HIM SAY SOMETHING AND
THEN YOU CAN RESPOND, ROCHELLE.
THAT WILL BE FINE.
>> YOU DIDN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION, YOU DISTRACTED BY
EVERYONE BY GOING TO
CHARLOTTESVILLE WHICH EVERYONE
DENOUNCED.
AND YET THEN YOU FABRICATED A
STORY THAT CLEAVER WAS SPIT ON.
HE WAS NOT SPIT ON, YOU ARE
MAKING THAT UP.
THESE ARE NONSENSE EVENTS.
YOU MADE IT ABOUT SOMETHING ELSE
OTHER THAN ANSWER THE QUESTION
WHICH FREQUENTLY LIBERALS DO.
>> I'M JUST GOING TO RESPOND BY
SAYING THIS.
FIRST OF ALL THAT STORY IS
COMPLETELY TRUE.
>> Laura: LET'S TRY TO KEEP
IT -- WE HAVE LIMITED TIME SO
LET'S KEEP IT FOCUSED TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
I THINK WE ALL DO CARE ABOUT
WHAT KIDS TAKE AWAY FROM THIS.
WHETHER IT'S KIDS IN AN
IMMIGRATION VIDEO SAYING F THE
PRESIDENT AND PUTTING UP THEIR
MIDDLE FINGER OR, PEOPLE GOING
UP TO INDIVIDUALS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN, THEIR FAMILY,
OTHERWISE AND THEIR HUSBANDS IN
A RESTAURANT AND SCREAMING THEM
OUT OF A RESTAURANT.
IT IS INCUMBENT UPON BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS TO
STAND UP AND SAY, NO.
YOU WILL NOT DO THIS.
WHEN ERIC HOLDER IS OUT THERE
SAYING, WE WILL KICK THEM --
MICHELLE OBAMA ACTUALLY SAID,
WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE WILL GO
HIGH.
APPARENTLY ERIC HOLDER SAYS, WE
ARE JUST GOING TO KICK THEM OR
EVEN WORSE.
>> I DON'T THINK SHE SHOULD
ASSAULT ANYONE BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER -- AND
IF PEOPLE GO BACK AND LOOK AT
WHAT ERIC HOLDER SAID, HE
FOLLOWED UP WITH THAT STATEMENT
SAYING WE SHOULD NOT DO ANYTHING
ILLEGAL OR INAPPROPRIATE.
>> Laura: SO GOING BACK TO THE
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT CONSUME MEDIA,
WHAT WILL THEY BE CONSUMING?
>> WE JUST CAN'T SIMPLY ADMIT
THAT PEOPLE MAKE MISTAKES AND
SAY REALLY DUMB THINGS.
NOW ERIC HOLDER WAS TALKING
ABOUT KICKING THEM OUT OF THE
HOUSE AND THAT IS NOT WHAT HE
SAID.
>> >> Laura: THIS IS FROM
RAND PAUL'S WIFE, KELLY.
SHE SAID THIS BACK ON
OCTOBER 8TH JUST A COUPLE OF
DAYS AGO.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY FRANKLY
UNHINGED PEOPLE AND UNSTABLE
PEOPLE OUT THERE, AND WHEN THEY
HEAR SOMEONE ON THEIR SIDE
TELLING THEM, GET UP IN YOUR
FACE, THEY TAKE THAT LITERALLY.
BECAUSE OF THE VIOLENCE THAT
RAND HAS EXPERIENCE IN THE LAST
YEAR, IT DOES SCARE ME THAT
LARRY WILL BE SOMEBODY REALLY
UNSTABLE THAT TAKES THAT MESSAGE
A STEP FURTHER.
WE'VE UPDATED ALL OF OUR
SECURITY SYSTEMS AT HOME.
I SLEEP WITH A LOADED GUN BY MY
BED.
>> DAN, FINAL THOUGHTS?
>> HE WAS ATTACKED AND HAD
BROKEN RIBS, HE'S APPARENTLY
COMING COMING DOWN WITH FREQUENT
CASES OF PNEUMONIA NOW.
THESE AREN'T FABRICATED CASES
LIKE THE SARAH PALIN PACT.
I JUST WISH THE LEFT WITH STEP
UP AND SAY, THIS IS ALL WRONG.